hey i'm mario lopez and i play ac slater
hi i'm elizabeth berkley lauren and i
play jesse spano what's up guys i'm
dexter darden and i play devonta young
hi i'm alicia pascual pena and i play
aisha garcia hi my name is josie and i
play lexi hey my name is belmont camelli
and i play jamie spano what's up i'm
husqvidi velazquez and i play daisy
jimenez hi i'm mitchell hogue and i play
mac morris we're the cast of saved by
the bell and we're here with buzzfeed to
play a game of who's who
[Music]
who is most likely to start laughing and
break character during a take that's
very
it's elizabeth berkley who is
a breaking character and laughing
okay it's you
okay i couldn't even get that out it's
you mitchell i was gonna say mitchell
too i think mitchell
remember that one scene where mitchell
could not
for the life of him i'm talking about
the hump day scene where it was really
just one line do you not remember hump
day
okay that was a that was just a bad
i got i died yeah okay it's literally me
talking to
everybody so there's like a bunch of the
background the whole cast i always
either go too low or they want me to go
really big so i was just like you know
whatever i'm just gonna go really big
with this and so i started just going
really really big to the point where it
confused everybody at first so then
everybody started laughing then i
couldn't get the big version out of my
head and so every single time hump day
came out i would literally just start
crying and laughing it took so much
strength for him to say hump day the
most simplest i feel like line just made
it so difficult who's most like their
character dexter
you are most like your character because
you can personally resonate with so many
parts of his storyline your commitment
to your friends like devante is so loyal
and so real dexter is that in real life
that is so sweet but i'm interested as
to why you said josie as well because i
kind of get the fashionista aspect yeah
i was just going to say the fashion need
to ask that rosie is like a
larger-than-life
personality she's captivating lexi is
reminiscent to josie just because of
like how phenomenal
their presence is yeah
but you're definitely the most like your
character you in high school yes because
the character was more based on me when
i was in high school now no as an adult
i'm gonna go with dexter maybe sensitive
thing right how about that devon yeah
i'm not too far from i mean i like i'd
hope i'm not as mean as her and i'm
definitely weirder than her you are less
mean and more strange i am more strange
which is sort of hard to believe i also
think elizabeth berkeley can be pretty
true to character sometimes oh yeah
they're like the same person josie and
mario i'd say yeah josie and mario for
sure who's least liked their character
now me
i would say husky knowing her you think
she's so different from yeah i think so
yeah it's got to be mitchell i think
belle is unlike jamie for sure thank god
he is more aware and uh intelligent than
jamie is but um mitchell is the most
unlikely character for sure nicole i
don't feel like mac at all that's the
best way to put that one re right re yes
i think my name's in the hat oh yeah
yeah i think you guys are equally
equidistant who is most likely to pull a
prank on fellow castmates nobody pulls
pranks but i would definitely say josie
is
a comedic legend and she does have bits
josie's just like the most brilliantly
funny of us humor that you would never
really expect everyone's really pro i
mean they're fun but they're they're pro
i feel like belle might have fun with
that i don't know okay bell sure mario
mario for sure we don't really prank
each other i think we just do things
that are stupid if i prank anybody it's
probably at least it's probably at least
yeah honestly i think we both torture
who's most likely to spam the group text
with a bunch of tick tocks
you
me
yeah for sure okay i would say between
me and like dexter that's probably me
that make all the kids do tick tocks
with me
dexter 100 that boy is on the internet
he dm's as memes he needs his tick tocks
dexter ah dang it it is me it is me it
is absolutely you and you know what's so
funny is like i'm very rarely on
tick-tock but i'm in so many group chats
that i'm constantly getting sent tic
tacs and then i'm always like oh i got
to send this to my family who's most
likely to give the best relationship
advice 100 percent me 100 i thought you
were just gonna say me i know i was
waiting for you
i don't know i say you i go to you guys
for different things dexter is like my
father and you're like my weird uncle
dex is just a knowledgeable wise
gentleman papadex for sure
he can understand everyone where
everyone is coming from and he's kind of
like that neutral person that gives that
that balance advice for sure i hate to
say myself again but i feel like i'm
kind of the oldest and have been in the
most relationships i kind of feel like
that's why i would say you too you well
you know this you're my big brother like
i go to you who's the best of doing
impressions with your other classmates
you do a lot of good impressions you're
lying right you tell me that all my
impressions sound the same well because
a lot of them do you have one register
that you lean on for they all sound the
same
it's not everybody but if there's a
specific demographic that you use that
registered for and it's always funny and
i always appreciate it i'm gonna go with
alicia just to mix it up maybe belle
okay he's good at that i think he's good
with like getting people's quirks down i
bet you josie's good probably
rosie yeah
all the time for fun like randomly will
become one of us and it's very
entertaining also very eye opening
because i'm like girl is that how i talk
or is that how you see me you're good at
it around your back yeah of course oh my
god i guess i'll do more i feel like
he's the easiest one sup
mama who's most likely to win a game of
saved by the bell trivia okay i think
mark paul now because of his podcast yes
100 percent i thought you might just
intrigue in trivia i would crush in
general say by the bell trivia i don't
know i don't remember anything
i just know a lot about the original
show so i i think that's probably why i
would be the most likely to win trivia
but alicia loki is slick like alicia
slick knows a lot about save by the bell
and she's also extremely intelligent so
if i'm one a i would say at least she
has one b
yeah that's what i was gonna say i feel
like we watched most of the original
season when it was coming out of the ogs
i think elizabeth would probably
destroy a trivia quiz i feel like she
has a photographic memory of everything
that's what happened elizabeth mario
mark paul just like the og
who's most likely to win an award for
best dress mitchell
oh duh i think mitchell has definitely
the most innovative like avant-garde
fashion in our show like he definitely
takes the most risk he's the fashionista
for sure that's probably you dud you
have a designer husband i have a
beautiful designer husband yeah and
jesse's clothes are great too mitchell i
like fashion actually i'm gonna i'm
gonna switch that i don't like fashion i
like style oh big difference there say
mitchell's then because he's the fashion
one mitchell's the fashion guy mittens
he's a fashion guy
you make fun of my stuff yeah i'm about
to
your sweet spot is like the the lazy
cheek you know i mean like you can put
together a crop top and a sweatpant like
nobody's business right it always looks
phenomenal i would say you have the
aesthetic of like
a
painter that's like french um that just
moved to brooklyn and is like eating a
lot of biscuits and a lot of milk who's
most likely to be caught napping between
takes alicia will sleep anywhere and
everywhere and she knows how to fall
asleep anywhere and everywhere that's
easy uh alicia alecia she's narcoleptic
we will literally be standing four
seconds of silence at like 11 p.m at
night and she's out like a light this
show because i actually have a photo of
you i told you this i sent it to you you
have a couple photos of me napping in
between takes so you're the one i'm not
into napping while working
i like to work out i'm most likely to
get caught napping then because i love
naps i never knew that about you 20
minutes boom hour i love it thank you
buzzfeed watch saved by the bell
streaming november 24th season 2 on
peacock
[Music]
you